[Musique]
alexander elena fouilles dans les ruines
de leurs maisons
nous étions ici dans le couloir quand la
maison a été bombardée s'étaient cachés
en est ressorti quand ça se termine et
tout est tombé sur ma main sur ma tête
nous avons essayé de nous protéger
à 150 km de la capitale ukrainienne la
ville de ge et home n'est pas à l'abri
des frappes russe ce bombardement a visé
des zones résidentielles
mais malgré cette détresse l'esprit est
à la résilience
[Musique]
nous allons tout reconstruire
nous allons planter à nouveau
les fondations sont solides nous allons
donc re bâtir dessus
oleksandr elena vivent aujourd'hui dans
un appartement prêté par un ami qui a
fait en france avec sa famille ils ne
sont pas encore très d'oublier cette
nuit de bombardement
je prends déjà des médicaments je n'ai
plus de larmes pour pleurer
la maison du couple se situe à quelques
centaines de mètres du siège de la 95e
régate d'assaut aérien une des plus
prestigieuses unités de l'armée
ukrainienne qui aurait été en ligne de
mire de l'armée russe de l'autre côté de
la rue se trouve la maternité de ge et
aux mails ici le personnel hospitalier
fait tout pour s'adapter au contexte de
guerre
actuellement nous travaillons au sous
sol pendant la nuit si nous avons une
urgence réf nous ne travaillons qui si
nous effectuons aussi des césariennes
accouchement naturel aussi
13 femmes étaient présentes à l'hôpital
lors de notre tournage certaines
attendent et d'accoucher et d'autres
venaient de le faire comme victoria qui
n'avait jamais imaginé que son
nouveau-né verrait le jour dans de
telles conditions
c'est un cadeau et je remercie le
personnel médical qui travaillent dans
ces conditions difficiles
c'est incroyable les choses qu'ils ont
fait est qu'ils font
ils ont donné de l'espoir à nous les
maires et à nos enfants
en regardant son fils reste elle
n'arrive pas à retenir ses larmes
ne souhaite à personne de vivre ce que
nous avons vécu
ce que nous ressentons maintenant
c'est une catastrophe j'espère que ça se
terminera le plus vite possible
victoire ya n'est pas la seule à avoir
été forcé à prendre la fuite ici âge et
aux mains la ville est devenue un centre
d'accueil pour tout ce qui fait qu'ils
élèvent et les régions bombardé
cette famille originaire de ce tome elle
a connu la vie sous l'occupation russe
il n'y avait même pas peint pendant deux
semaines il n'y avait plus rien dans les
magasins les troupes russes ont tout
pillé vous allez d'une maison à l'autre
défoncer les serrures et les portes
criais aux gens aller en russie
l'ukraine c'est le mal la russie c'est
le bien quand nous sommes partis nous
n'avions plus de gaz ils l'ont coupé en
disant que c'était du gaz russe
nous sommes cachés nous avons quitté
notre abri quand il n'y avait plus de
colonne ennemie
nous avions peur
lorsque nous entendons les sirènes à
jitomir nous pensons qu'ils peuvent nous
atteindre même ici il ne reste plus rien
là bas niveau
ce père de famille ne comprend toujours
pas le sens de cette guerre
notre territoire ne vous suffit pas
vraiment qu'on ne suffit pas
que voulez vous de plus de l'ukraine
journée
avant de poursuivre son périple vers
l'ouest cette famille recevra de l'aide
dans un centre comme celui ci
ici les équipes se plie en quatre pour
répondre aux très nombreuses
sollicitations
ses tubes et cinq fois
[Musique]
mais ces demandes ne viennent pas
seulement des déplacés depuis le début
de l'invasion russe les prix des denrées
alimentaires flambent ce qui empêche
beaucoup de familles de pouvoir subvenir
à leurs besoins tout cela a rendu ma vie
impossible toute ma famille est au
chômage et dépend de moi avant cela nous
vivions des réserves de nourriture que
nous avions encore d'autres résidents
qui n'ont pas réussi à se familiariser
avec le système en place ont vu leur
demande rejetée
ils nous ont dit que nous ne pouvions
pas obtenir d'être tant que nous ne nous
étions pas inscrits mais je ne sais pas
comment faire il m'est très difficile
d'utiliser internet ce serait beaucoup
plus facile si nous pouvions simplement
nous inscrire sur place et obtenir de
l'aide le lendemain
qu'il s'agisse d'accueillir les réfugiés
de distribuer l'aide humanitaire ou même
de sécuriser les villes les maires
jouent un rôle crucial dans ce
dispositif à l'hôtel de ville le maire
de jérôme nous a confié n'être pas
rentrer chez lui depuis le début du
conflit
la menace est omniprésente et même
durant l'entretien qu'il nous a accordé
les sirènes ont encore une fois retenti
nous nous dirigeons vers les abris de
telle alerte autant tissage et aux mails
à longueur de journée obligeant de la
population à se terrer dans des lieux
sûrs
dans l'abri de la mairie seront menées
in nous parle de la photo accrochée
derrière son bureau un portrait du
mahatma gandhi dont les valeurs
pacifistes étaient proches des siennes
mais devant l'impossibilité de dialoguer
porter des armes était devenue pour lui
inévitables
shahzad et quelques niveaux d'eau
quelques jours avant la guerre
j'ai parlé aux hommes avec lesquels je
m'étais entraîné et qui servent
maintenant en russie
je leur ai dit nous avons passé beaucoup
de temps ensemble à l'académie militaire
nous avons tous mangé dans la même
marmite
nous avons tous dormi sous le même ciel
mais si vous venez ici
nous vous tuerons
se défendre contre l'ennemi et défendre
leur propre territoire c'est ce que
continue de faire les ukrainiens et même
si les troupes russes semblent se
détourner aujourd'hui de la capitale
kiev ici achètent aux marques comme
ailleurs beaucoup se demandent s'ils
pourront prochainement reprendre une vie
normale